[Musique]
bonjour et merci de nous retrouver dans
le cqp loisirs toutes vos idées sorties
dans le département on commence tout de
suite avec le sommaire de ce numéro un
festival d'art urbain en soutien aux
enfants atteints de troubles du langage
c'est ce dimanche au mesnil saint denis
graffeur danseurs photographe et
musicien se retrouvent pour une journée
d'animations et de démonstrations
la responsable de l'événement sera avec
nous pour mans-paris air l'expo qui
inspire termine son tour d'île de france
à saint quentin en yvelines une
exposition le visiteur est également
acteur de nombreux ateliers sont
proposés et il va y avoir du sport ce
week end pour la fête de la ville de
montigny le bretonneux des allures de
jeux olympiques au parc de la couldre
mélanie boukhennou sentira plus dans
notre rendez-vous junior à guyancourt
plusieurs associations de la ville
expose les oeuvres de leurs élèves
jusqu'au 28 juin ces travaux sont le
résultat de différents ateliers proposés
par exemple par guyancourt accueil ou
encore l'amicale laïque
entre peinture sculpture ou mosaïque
cette exposition permet aux jeunes
artistes de goûter à la notoriété
bénédicte alliés coyne adjointe à la
culture nous en dit plus l'idée c'était
de d'élargir un autre public de façon à
ce que le vivre ensemble des
associations soient encore plus marquée
il ya à peu près 150 oeuvres
chaque artiste artistes enfants adultes
parce que on a beaucoup d'enfants je
dirais 50% d'enfants en peuvent exposer
en travail individuel donc une oeuvre
est un travail collectif une oeuvre
aussi
donc en fait il ya aussi beaucoup de
travail collectif est toujours à
guyancourt ce samedi 24 j'en ai quartier
seront en fête à l'occasion de la fête
de la musique dès 14 heures de
nombreuses animations sont proposées
dans toute la ville à partir de 18
heures une trentaine d'artistes se
produiront sur cinq scènes différentes à
la batterie direction de château de
breteuil à présent pour un voyage dans
le temps ce dimanche à choisel venez
revivre la journée du 3 mai 1905 une
reconstitution historique de la
réception donnée par le marquis de
breteuil pour célébrer l'entente
cordiale avec le roi edward c
d'angleterre du grand salon mon jardin
une quarantaine de comédiens vous
attendent en costumes d'époque
les visiteurs sont eux aussi invités à
se costumer intrigue à la cour repas
festif et grand bal 1 plongeant au coeur
de l'histoire puisque mon grand père
henri de breteil a été un des proches du
roi d'angleterre edouard 7 qui va très
très bien connu dans parmi les
personnages costumés on va retrouver le
roi d'angleterre
l'ambassadeur d'angleterre cette époque
mon grand père ma grand-mère et des
personnages célèbres de cette époque
comme la comtesse très fils qui étaient
là ce fameux jour qui 3905 mais il ya
beaucoup de choses qui vont se passer
aussi à l'extérieur on est vraiment dans
dans un côté très festif dans une
réception dans la restitution aussi
d'une vie mondaine puisque véritablement
henry breteuil et sa femme marcelle ita
garner côtoyaient marcel proust
côtoyaient la comtesse greffulhe toutes
les têtes couronnées aussi d'europe
donc voilà c'est c'est ce voyage dans
l'histoire qu'il propose une trentaine
d'artistes de street art réunis pour un
festival en soutien aux enfants qui
souffrent de difficultés de langage le
festival articule inaugure ce dimanche
sa première édition au mesnil saint
denis et c'est véronique bush dit
présidente de la maison du langage et
organismes organisatrice de l'événement
keaven dévoilé le programme bonjour
bonjour merci d'être avec nous alors on
va parler de cette manifestation qui
regroupe des danseurs des graffeurs des
photographes et même des cinéastes
si vous pouvez nous les présenter un
petit peu leur qui sont ils donc le jour
du festival à une douzaine d'artistes
graffeurs qui graff rond en live devant
leur le public donc ces graffeurs sont
des graffeurs connu son plan national
international actuellement
par exemple raf urban qui nous a offert
une oeuvre exposée aux réhab à la
ténacité dont l'internât à la cité u
l'internât des arts et métiers et donc
on peut les retrouver dans paris un peu
partout on peut retrouver à londres à
new york un bref et viennent donc au
menu samedi pour nous soutenir pour les
enfants qui ont des troubles du langage
il y aura aussi des danseurs vous nous
en dire un peu plus sur les danseurs les
musiciens donc pareil y aura des
danseurs donc ses danseurs une troupe
semi amateurs qui s'appelle les failles
spi et puis gaël grzeskowiak on a vu
d'ailleurs avant-hier à la télé qu'il
faisait la fête de la musique à toulouse
avec des artistes chanteurs donc voilà
il nous prépare un duo avec chanel bush
dit qu' elle aussi chantent pour des
artistes et ils nous présenteront un duo
en danse contemporaine ou que vous
l'avez dire ils feront à beaucoup de
démonstrations des performances auprès
du public
voilà ils vont intervenir à peu près
trois fois dans l'après-midi pour nous
présenter une chorégraphie avec la
troupe fights piste
très bien et on y rappelle alors vous
êtes la présidente de la maison
ambulants gâché la première édition de
ce festival
qu'est ce qui a motivé sa création alors
tous les ans fait notre association
organise une grande journée de
prévention
donc je vais avec l'idée d'informer au
maximum le grand public sur les troubles
du langage de l'enfant
cette année notre idée c'était le
mélange et arrêts
les sujets sérieux et donc de s'appuyer
particulièrement sur l'art puisque la
langage universel donc les artistes ont
joué le jeu et ça va être l'occasion de
parler dans une grande détente de ces
fameux troubles du langage qui handicape
sérieusement le parcours de certains en
font alors les troubles du langage qu
est ce que cela comprend 7 août maladie
un petit peu en dise c'est ça alors
toutes les maladies on dit souvent
qu'ils ne sont donc qui entraîne des
troubles des apprentissages dyslexie
dysorthographie dyspraxie dysphasie et
certains troubles du langage qui
atteignent plus le
le langage oral et donc qui gêne les
interactions avec les personnes et des
maladies parfois plus ou moins connus en
a dix sélections on connaît tous les
autres n'a peut-être pas beaucoup
entendu parler c'est important de
sensibiliser le public à ces
problèmes-là jeu là ça me paraît
important et parce que les enfants ont
souvent un parcours scolaire qui est
quand même très compliqué avec des
parents qui doivent se battre au
quotidien pour leurs enfants pour faire
entendre leurs besoins et trouver des
moyens de compensation pour qu'il puisse
suivre une scolarité classique et puis
ensuite trouver leur place dans la
société
donc il y aura des témoignages également
d'artistes atteint eux mêmes de ce type
de trouble voilà donc on aura le
témoignage de clémence
darnaud peyroche qui est aussi la
graphiste qui a fait toute la
communication visuelle du festival qui
souffre d'une dyslexie dysorthographie
sévère mais ça n'a pas empêché de faire
des études et donc pour son mémoire de
fin d'étude elle a créé un tout une
recherche l'a fait une recherche la
manière dont les personnes d
orthographique résonne autour du langage
écrit et elle en a tiré un livre d'art
qui s'appelle je crois le petit prince
et les troubles dyslexiques
elle va nous présenter donc pour la
première fois en france à ce festival
donc on pourra venir la rencontrer
d'ivoire ou encore la voir lui poser des
questions et voir de livres et un
dernier mot sur le lieu car cela a son
importance aux six ans le festival se
déroulera dans la ferme de chant garnier
et du coup pour la restauration pourra
également profiter de produits du
terroir tout à faire en fait on a fait
le choix de cette ferme ce qu'on voulait
créer un choc culturel amener l'art
l'art urbain à la campagne donc une
ferme n'a rien de mieux que ça et puis
nous avons trouvé donc de fermiers
didier florence de huit qui ont trouvé
enfin qui se sont investis eux aussi
pour notre cause et donc qu'ils nous ont
offert la possibilité d'utiliser tous
leurs espaces et
ils ont choisi d'organiser la partie
restauration donc on pourra venir manger
sur place
on peut aussi pique-niqué et peut-être
la journée pour moi j'ai des crêpes des
gâteaux
merci beaucoup en tout cas veronica
bougie est revenue sur le plateau du
seti loisirs pour nous parler de cet
événement alors on le rappelle vous êtes
attendus dimanche 25 juin à la ferme de
chant garnier de 10 heures à 20 heures
l'entrée est gratuite et les navettes
sont mises à disposition pour accéder
facilement à la ferme merci beaucoup
veronica c'est une exposition
participative a débuté à lille de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines une
exposition autour de l'air porté par
plusieurs associations en partenariat
avec des citoyens
les précisions avec ce reportage de
nicolas kirillovitch kirillovitch et
yves hepp stone berger invisible mais
indispensable à toute forme de vie l'air
s'installe au coeur d'une exposition sur
l'île de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines le climat la respiration ou
encore les odeurs plusieurs thématiques
sont abordées pour comprendre
l'interaction entre l'homme et l'air une
exposition aussi pédagogique interactive
les yvelines sont la dernière étape d'un
voyage débuter en 2016 et qui a parcouru
toute l'île de france
cette exposition elle n'est pas figée au
fur et à mesure des deux mois
d'installation
on espère je pense que ça devrait bien
arriver que les gens qui vont visiter
vont avoir envie de participer et de
s'exprimer
à l'intérieur de cette exposition
soutenue notamment par la région
l'exposition a déjà été visitée par
quarante mille personnes depuis un an et
demi
ce jour-là à lille de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines l'atelier pour les
enfants est consacrée aux cerfs-volants
s'il n'y a pas de vins le cerf-volant va
toujours rester par terre et il ne va
pas voler alors que le vent il va tenir
le cerf-volant
dans les airs et puis ça va voler ça va
bouger
en arrivant dans une région c'est ça qui
fait tout son intérêt
elle va s'enrichir localement de toutes
les contributions des gens qui la visite
à ce moment dans cette région dans cette
île dans ce département
donc ici dans les yvelines on espère que
les citoyens des yvelines vont pouvoir
apporter une contribution vraiment
locales sur peut-être la qualité de
l'air air l'expo qui inspire est à
découvrir jusqu'au 30 juillet à saint
quentin en yvelines
d après midi spéciales sont prévues
régulièrement les week-ends avec des
chercheurs et professionnels
[Musique]
montigny le bretonneux va tester vos
qualités sportives ce dimanche c'est la
fête de la ville et mélanie poker
heureusement que vous êtes là pour nous
en dire plus bonjour il a ni eau jean
cagnard cette fête de la ville est
placée sous le signe du sport dics amis
et c'est la deuxième fois que le sport à
cet honneur il a toute cette année il a
toute sa place cette année puisque c'est
son limpide clôture une semaine dédiée
aux jeux olympiques vous le savez vous
le savez peut-être paris est candidate
pour recevoir les géo en 2024 et
montigny le bretonneux pourrait
accueillir certaines épreuves notamment
du cyclisme et qui dit olympiades dix
épreuves dans ces deux c'est le parc des
sports de la coudre qui va accueillir
cette après midi festive les
participants vont s'affronter entre
quartiers les huit quartiers de la ville
seront représentés par une couleur et le
mieux c'est d'écouter marie toussaint
adjointe au maire déléguée à
l'événementiel elle nous en dit un peu
plus à la tente accueil qui viendront
récupérer une carte
cette carte de 30 points sera à
présenter lorsqu'ils feront un défi sur
soi les structures gonflables donc on a
une dizaine de structures gonflables
soit sur les trente activités sportives
associations sportives qui seront
présentes pour faire découvrir leurs
activités ces activités sportives seront
encadrés par les associations de la
ville il y aura notamment un entraîneur
à l'arrivée de l'épreuve derrière il y
aura une surprise et en retrouvant il en
aura pour tous les goûts du relevé du
golf du football de la gym du judo du
tir à la du basket de l'escroc c'est
compliqué de faire la liste complète et
l'entrée est libre les épreuves débutent
à 14 heures et mélanie il a fait très
chaud ces derniers jours qu'est ce qui
est prévu pour les participants qui sera
un petit peu inquiet alors bien sûr
montigny-le-bretonneux a pensé à tout
puisque il y aura un brumisateur géant
qui sera installé pour rafraîchir à les
participants il y aura aussi une buvette
et cette année cette fête de la ville et
donc une après midi familial à vivre dès
3 ans merci beaucoup mélanie nous allons
parler de cet événement est ce que vous
y serez on pourra vous défier peut-être
enfin au plan de tir à l'arc à on
essaiera l'on vous pour d'autres car
alors qu'en tout cas avis aux sportifs
et aux non sportifs aussi en tout cas
c'est le moment de venir défier vos amis
et on passe maintenant à notre agenda
[Musique]
du 30 juin au 2 juillet le cinéma sera à
l'honneur à rambouillet pour la sixième
édition du festival court dans la forêt
de nombreux courts métrages seront à
découvrir au cinéma vox vous pourrez
déjà réserver vos places dès mercredi 28
juin et on termine sur un peu de douceur
à thoiry les trois lionceaux né en mars
font leurs premiers pas à l'extérieur
à cette occasion le zoo a dévoilé leurs
prénoms choisis par les internautes
à l'issue d'un vote coumba et kyle a
pour les femelles et kassaï pour le mal
il vous restait deux ans auprès de leur
mère et kassaï partira ensuite fonder sa
propre famille dans un autre groupe de
lyon c'est la fin de ce set 8 loisirs
merci de nous avoir suivis je vous
retrouve vendredi prochain pour un
nouveau numéro et je vous souhaite un
excellent week end
et oh